desde que tengo memoria me encantan las
historias por eso todo el tiempo estoy
consumiendo libros películas y
televisión cuando era niña veía una
película a diario y si tenía suerte mi
papá me contaba una historia antes de
dormir me encantaban los personajes mis
favoritos eran los aventureros y audaces
que siempre iban tras lo que querían
también me encantaban los inteligentes
que con sagacidad se salían con la suya
y me divertía mucho imitando los
atuendos de los que me resultaban
extravagantes oliver de los
supercampeones aladdin con su changuito
y rompe el skin eran algunos de mis
preferidos es así que cuando tenía 3
años creé un personaje para mí le nombre
job garcía job bestia companys y
conjuntos de futbolista mi favorito era
el del portero jorge campos con el que
aparezco en esta foto
job corría y grababa cápsulas de
televisión en una pequeña cámara que
teníamos en la casa en algunas historias
yo trabajaba en un circo y en otras eran
más formales traía un saco y un bigote
de papel mientras era entrevistada por
mi padre quien también la hacía de
camarógrafo
esta etapa que recuerdo como muy libre
creativa y divertida terminó pronto pues
un día alguien me hizo notar que job y
yo no teníamos mucho que ver pues juego
hacía cosas de niño y yo era niña aunque
yo lo hubiera pensado vivido y creado a
mi manera job no era un personaje para
mí y yo no entendía por qué
este momento que podría pasar por una
simple anécdota infantil para mí
significa mucho más
fue el primer choque contra un monstruo
gigante de ahí surgió una pregunta cómo
sería un personaje para mí
en mi inocencia infantil no era capaz
siquiera de vislumbrar el recorrido que
tendría que hacer para encontrar una
respuesta a esta búsqueda se
transformaría en un proyecto de vida
y comencé este viaje sola pues creía que
era la única rara que no se identificaba
con los personajes que aparecían en la
tele y películas
y este choque me duró toda la niñez y
juventud
primero me costaba identificarme en las
princesas y creo que esto no es nada
raro porque seguramente muchas más
batallan en identificarse con un
personaje que pasa toda su vida
durmiendo o con uno que se case con la
primera persona que encuentre su zapato
perdido
después estaban las mujeres de acción
rudas e impecables increíbles pero
siempre secundarias y de qué te sirve
ser tan perfecta si tu única recompensa
será que el galán en turno te haga caso
más adelante descubrí otras les llamaban
manic pixie drink grow eran lindas
coquetas simpáticas y con increíbles
gustos musicales
siempre como un sueño de un protagonista
y bueno
yo adolescente un poco tímida no
contestó na y llena de opiniones siempre
me sentía muy tosca en comparación
había otras que parecían diferentes eran
cool y libres de dramas bebían mucha
cerveza y amaban los deportes tenían
muchos amigos y no les molestaba cuando
hombres hacían comentarios misóginos
aunque éstos hicieran daño a otras
mujeres
bueno yo no les voy a no les voy a dejar
no les voy a mentir a mí me encanta la
cerveza y nunca le digo que no una chevy
pero qué flojera tener que soportar y
fingir que no me molestan los
comentarios machistas solo para tener
con quien ver el fútbol y bueno
seguramente me faltan muchísimas más
pero creo que ya se pueden hacer una
idea de mi situación y no les voy a
negar que en muchas ocasiones intenté
encajar en muchos de esos roles que se
me presentaban la mayoría de las
ocasiones a costa de mi propio bienestar
y muchas veces me llegué a sentir
inadecuada me sentía demasiado demasiado
cobarde demasiado grande demasiado
inteligente demasiado mandona demasiada
demasiado demasiado demasiado
a su vez y esto se los confieso con
muchísima vergüenza en muchas otras
ocasiones me llegue a encontrar a mí
misma queriendo hacer encajar a otras
mujeres en esos mismos roles que a mí me
limitaban
pensando en ellas como personajes planos
y lo peor
creyendo que ellas y yo teníamos muy
poco que ver un machismo aprendido que
por mucho tiempo me hizo sentir rara y
sola
afortunadamente para mí no continúe en
este camino por mucho tiempo pues como
les platiqué siempre seguir buscando así
a los 17 años me encontré con mi primer
acompañante
marian satrapi y aunque no la conocí
personalmente su película persépolis
vino hay que enviar mi perspectiva
persépolis
además de ser narrada a través de la
mirada de una mujer
trata temas complejos y su protagonista
es activa e inteligente incluso su
rebeldía la llega a llevar al autoexilio
aunque la película está hablada en
francés y situada en irán yo encontré
muchas coincidencias entre mi
experiencia personal y la protagonista
por primera vez me vi en pantalla y me
encantó a quien no le gusta verse
identificada en un personaje lo que más
me gusta de esta historia es que margin
no solo es retratada de manera heroica
la historia le dona matices ella a veces
no está orgullosa de su nacionalidad
muchas veces le cuesta mucho trabajo
encajar en otras ocasiones le va muy mal
en el amor y en y varias veces no tiene
ni la más mínima idea de qué es lo que
debe de hacer y lo mejor
ninguno de estos defectos le resta ni
autodeterminación ni agencia
algo que me resulta muy curioso es que
escuchando entrevistas hacia la autora
ella ha dicho que nunca ha intentado
hacer un filme feminista ni siquiera un
modelo de representación de género
ella no busca crear un panfleto lo que
quiere es contar su historia porque
hasta el momento en que se creó la
película ella estaba harta de escuchar
tantas historias de su país que no
resonaban con su experiencia muy similar
a lo que a mí me ocurría con los
personajes
porque la historia de satrapi me resultó
tan significativa tal vez sería porque
fue escrita por una mujer
una de las autoras que más reflexionó al
respecto fue virginia woolf
en la situación de wolf era muy
diferente a la mía porque en la época en
la que ella creció el acceso a las
mujeres a la cultura era muchísimo más
complicado y ni se diga las
representaciones en las historias en su
libro una habitación propia de 1929 que
fue el primero que leí de ella
virginia hace una reflexión y una
denuncia que comienza cuando no se le
permite entrar a la biblioteca de la
universidad donde trabajaba porque no
iba acompañada de un hombre de este
libro se desprende una frase que ya es
un clásico
una mujer necesita dinero y una
habitación propia para poder escribir
una novela
la falta de independencia económica
hizo que la que las mujeres no
trascendiera mos la tradición oral y que
comenzáramos a crear nuestras propias
historias las obras de mujeres que
surgieron en esa época y salieron y
llegaron a la luz pública fueron
poquísimas en comparación con las de
hombres
qué pasó entonces la mayoría de las
mujeres fueron creadas por autores
masculinos
la pregunta aquí es si estamos
conscientes de todo lo que nos hemos
perdido al no conocer el otro lado de la
historia el lado que nos devuelve la
mirada esta idea
se sostuvo por mucho tiempo bajo la
premisa de que las mujeres no éramos ni
tan inteligentes ni tan originales como
los hombres manteniéndonos por muchos
siglos en un rol de servidumbre
como se mantiene una idea así por tanto
tiempo
si nos remontamos a la tradición
grecorromana podemos identificar que
esta es de facto misógina en la antigua
grecia
las mujeres no eran consideradas
ciudadanas ni siquiera tenían el derecho
a la voz pública los únicos asuntos de
los que se podían hacer cargo eran del
hogar de los asuntos personales y de sus
hijos el discurso público era el
definitorio de la masculinidad y esto lo
podemos ver en mitos como por ejemplo el
de la ninfa eco condenada a la eternidad
a hablar exclusivamente para repetir lo
que otros decían es así que las mujeres
al crear al intentar ser literatos
artistas o cineastas nos encontramos con
muchos obstáculos no sólo materiales y
económicos también simbólicos
hay muchas ideas que afectan nuestra
psique e impulso creador creando una una
sensación de que si las mujeres no
publicamos no tenemos películas sea
probablemente porque no somos lo
suficientemente buenas esta creencia se
alimenta de una discriminación temática
que está cimentada en un canon el canon
de la cultura es un supuesto crítico que
asume que hay historias más importantes
que otras así las historias que tratan
de guerras y peleas suelen ser
consideradas mayores que las que ocurren
en lugar lo autobiográfico o lo
cotidiano y qué pasa que muchas mujeres
precisamente crean este tipo de
historias desde lo cotidiano y desde las
emociones y yo no estoy diciendo que
esto sea una preferencia que se deba al
sexo con que una nace por el contrario
es un tema de género
las experiencias a las que nos exponemos
las mujeres desde que somos pequeñas son
muchísimo más limitadas que las de los
hombres todo esto porque la cultura nos
limita a su vez se ha relegado a la
mujer al espacio privado mientras que es
el hombre quien ocupa el espacio público
más fácilmente las historias que ocurren
en el hogar lo autobiográfico o lo
cotidiano no son menores
simplemente muestran el punto de vista
de quien las enuncia y suelen ser la
mirada que había sido dejada de lado
conocer a estas autoras fue el primer
paso en un viaje que me llevó a conocer
a muchísimas más ya no solo literatas
autoras o cineastas también
contar mi historia y escuchar la de
otras mujeres me llevó a encontrarme en
las de cada una de ellas todas las
mujeres que me rodeaban en mi madre en
mi hermana en mis abuelas en mis primas
en mis amigas y compañeras qué
importante darse cuenta que no una no es
rara bueno tal vez sí pero no por eso
ni está sola la falta de representación
en las películas es un problema
sistemático no mío todas las
inconformidades que yo les platiqué que
viví en mi niñez y adolescencia son
nuestros
y es importante traerlos a la luz y
problematizar un tema que se había
normalizado las representaciones
femeninas en la cultura no son
suficientes
la solución a este problema no reside en
crear nuevos estereotipos donde encajar
nos
tampoco basta con que se nos ponga a
pelear con niñas mientras utilizamos
shorts apretados o armaduras que no nos
protegen
no basta con que se nos re trate como
seres misteriosos no basta con que los
escritores cambien el género de sus
personajes de acción para cumplir con
una cuota
es necesario que escritoras y escritores
hagan bien su trabajo comiencen a crear
personajes complejos es necesario que se
abra la abra el espacio a nuevas voces
voces de mujeres que filmen y narran sus
propias historias es necesario que se
rompan con las brechas de contratación
en el cine y la cultura
es necesario que abandonemos la falsa
idea de que un producto cultural creado
por una mujer es para es exclusivamente
para mujeres y que un producto creado
por un hombre es para todo el mundo
imagino y me lleno de emoción pensando
en las niñas y como cambiaría su
autopercepción al comenzar a verse y
saberse escuchadas dejar de ser objetos
de una trama y comenzar a hacer agentes
de una vida
somos la otra mitad del mundo una mitad
que quiere también ser vista narrada y
escuchada achicarnos al espacio al que
se nos había relegado ya no es opción
yo por mi parte sigo creando y pensando
siempre añadiendo a mis historias y a mi
propio y permanente personaje una mujer
a la que a job le gusta ser
[Aplausos]